for someone like me he wasn't lucky
enough to meet your sister there are any
particular memories that you have of her
that paint a picture of the kind of
woman that she was oh we're very lucky
we've got lots of really fantastic
memories of Joe and birth from our
childhood but also from our time as
adults together and you know everything
that we did together was fun you know
Joe was the nicest kindest person you
could hope to meet she was also
extremely talented but but she didn't
have any sort of ego or agenda she just
wanted to help people and whatever she
did in her career and her life that's
what she did so she worked in the in the
voluntary sector for a long time
overseas and then she came back to to
the UK to work in the area where we grew
up and make a difference to the lives of
people in the community where I still
live and how will you be remembering her
today well today we've actually got a
game of rugby league the memorial game
injures name I'll put that Lee Bulldogs
rugby club so I will be surrounded by
the fantastic team of volunteers who
have supported myself and mom and dad
since Joe was killed and will be paying
tribute to Joe through the power of
sport which I think has got a fantastic
role in bringing people together which
was exactly what you believed in that is
a really a great way to remember how I
think now do you think that our politics
has become more or less tolerant in the
three years since her death oh yeah I
mean I think unfortunately things felt
pretty bad in June 2016 when Joe was
killed but I think it's probably fair to
say that they have got progressively
worse there was a short period of time
where politicians and other people said
you know we have to do things
differently in the aftermath of Joe's
murder but I think it's fair to say that
since that time things you know just got
progressively worse and I think now is
is an opportunity reflecting on Joe's
murder to think actually let's let's all
try and do something to change that
let's all try and do something to move
things forward absolutely nothing wrong
with robust a bit and and passionate
discussion you know we live in a
democracy in a country that which I'm so
proud where we can do those things but
actually we also need to treat each
other with respect and civility and I
think then we've lost sight of that a
little bit in recent times why do you
think it is that the nature of our
political discourse does seem so
aggressive I mean do you think that
social media for example plays a role in
this I think I think there's several
factors
like with most things that you know it's
it's complex but I think social media
definitely plays its part but equally
social media can be used to do many good
things it's a power to create a real
positive change and positive messages
but yeah I think the anonymity that
social media provides is quite dangerous
at times I think clearly breaks it has
you know changed things filling this
country well it's done what she's really
powerful is it's mobilized people who
who wouldn't have been engaged with
politics before but I think actually the
nature of that debate now again you know
has it has changed you know I make no
judgment on how you vote whether you
know your which have a political party
or how you voted on brexit but what I'm
interested in is why why did you feel
that way how do you you know and how do
we come together to try and reunite the
country in the middle of all of all this
division yeah definitely I think a good
way of approaching that I do also want
to get your opinion on a joke that was
made by Jay Brandis received a lot of
attention this week of course she was
referring to people throwing milkshake
at politicians and she says why bother
with a milkshake when you could get some
battery acid what's your view on that
yeah I mean it's very hard for me to be
wholly objective on that subject because
of because of what we've been through
but but I don't think there is a place
in in politics or sometimes in comedy
for the use of a violent language and I
think you know no one wants to stop
comedians doing their job no one wants
to stop politicians doing their job but
I think if you have a public role and
indeed if you don't have a public role
we have to all take responsibility for
the language we use and the things that
we say so I don't say that to
politicians I would say that's a
journalist so I would say to comedians
and I think the other thing I would say
is you know the way that politics is at
the moment I wouldn't have thought there
was a shortage of material for comedians
so and I don't think using you know
violent rhetoric is is helpful and I
think you know but everybody also think
it's a tricky one who sets the moral
compass of the nation who decides what's
funny who decides what's offensive and
that and that varies from person to
person but I think you know if you had a
conversation with anybody who has been
the victim of an acid attack or has had
a family member that's been attacked in
such a horrific way they certainly
wouldn't find that for me thank you and
for answering that so openly now and
finally you've done some really amazing
work haven't you to try and make sure
that your sisters memory lives on that
her legacy is really powerful
what do you think that legacy will be
and I hope you know in the months and
the years to come that we can create a
real powerful legacy for Joe based
around bringing people together based
around focusing on the common values and
the things that we share as human beings
you know I think again because passions
are running so high at the moment and
we're focusing very much on the things
that we disagree on we sometimes need to
reconnect on a human level and think
about the things that we share you know
it's easy to be negative it's easy to be
angry I'm angry believe me about what's
happened to us but what I'm not doing is
giving in to that anger and I'm not
giving in to the negative emotions I'm
trying to do something positive and in
terms of do something in Joe's name but
also in terms of you know something that
this country needs where we can bring
people together and reconnect on a human
level and I think you know we all need
to take responsibility to do that
whether we are politicians and I'm not
aligned to any particular political
party you know whoever you are wherever
you sit on the political spectrum think
about the rule that you have and think
about the the fortunate position that
you're in where you can make a
difference to this country but trying to
in a positive way and again the media
you know we've all got a responsibility
to do something positive and that that's
what I'm focusing in terms of Joe's
legacy and it's hard don't get me wrong
it's hard you know I have days when I
could easily give in to the despair and
the the upset that I feel but I'm not
going to do that but what we have to do
is stop shouting at each other and we
need to start listening to each other
we need to start trying to understand
other people's positions and
perspectives and that's what we're
trying to do through Joe's foundation
you know and while ever I've got the
strength in my bones that's that's what
I'm going to focus on for Joe for her
kids and for the country as a whole but
for anybody who has lost anybody you
know under under the horrific
circumstances that we have whether
that's in the terrorist attacks in
Manchester whether it's really rigged
this family you know whether it's
anybody you know that doesn't matter to
me we have to take our responsibility to
try and make a positive difference
really seriously and and I guess you
know that's what I'm trying to do as
best I can